bonsoir à tous tapez robot sur internet
et vous aurez probablement cette
définition un robot ce serait une
machine un automate à l'aspect humain
capable d'agir et de parler comme un
être humain
ça c'est la vision qu'on connaît tous
conduite c'est celle que dessinent les
enfants c'est celle que j'appelle moi la
robotique à papa on la retrouve depuis
tout le temps et et ça consiste à avoir
un robot avec des moteurs des
actionneurs des capteurs des algues au
rythme tout intégré
si on détruit le corps du robot ont
détruit le robot est d'ailleurs la
science fiction nous a fourni beaucoup
d'exemples à ce propos là on a bien sûr
c3po de qu'on retrouve dans star wars on
a wholly en astro boy parfois même dans
ses films
ces robots sont amenés à mourir ou où on
a de la peine pour et dans tous les cas
ces robots sont présentés comme ayant de
l'émotion plus récemment il ya des
robots c'est plus des dessins animés
c'est la réalité des robots comme ça qui
arrive je peux citer asimo c'est le
robot humanoïde de honda on peut citer
le chien robot de sony qui s'appelle
live beau et il ya également ce robot le
robot peppers auquel j'ai beaucoup
participé à la création car je suis
concepteur du robot de robots et c'est
comme ça qu'on faisait les robots
jusqu'à présent alors je suis très très
fier de ce qu'on a fait mais on doit
on doit accepter ensemble que ça
correspond à une vision du robot qui est
aujourd'hui en partie révolue nous ici
dans cette pièce on est beaucoup
appartenir à cette génération y c'est
une génération qui s'est construit
autour d'internet sur une idée que le
logiciel que l'information commence à se
séparer est complètement même séparé du
de son support matériel
elle peut être ici là bas sur un serveur
sur elle peut se déplacer et peut se
synchroniser se télécharger en fait elle
est devenue vraiment indépendante du
matériel et ça ça invite à reconsidérer
complètement la manière dont on peut
concevoir un robot ou concevoir une
intelligence artificielle
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on voit des
nouvelles générations une interface
vocale notamment des personnages vocaux
avec lequel on va interagir que vous
connaissez déjà c'est google home amazon
avec sa notamment mais il y en a il y en
a beaucoup d'autres et c'est ces
interfaces qui s'installe dans notre
quotidien et bien elles sont déjà des
intelligences diffuse on peut les avoir
chez nous sur nos téléphones portables
sur nos montres on peut les convoquer à
peu près à n'importe quel moment
oui mais voilà elle s'installe comme
sachant à peu près tout on peut leur
poser à peu près n'importe quelle
question
et elles sont supposées pouvoir répondre
à toutes
à toutes ces questions elle voit
énormément de choses sur nous elles
connaissent beaucoup de choses sur nos
déplacements sur nos habitudes etc et on
nous annonce qu'elles vont bientôt être
plus intelligente que nous et ça c'est
un peu troublant quand on y pense parce
qu'on installe quelque chose que nous on
voit pas mais qu'ils nous voient qui
sait tout sur nous mais nous on sait
rien de ça c'est un peu comme une
position qui pourrait ressembler à celle
à celle d'un dieu et ça c'est un peu
étrange et d'ailleurs la science fiction
là aussi un peu repris à son compte un
peu complètement
bien sûr les exemples vous les
connaissez c'est hal 9000 de 2001 2001
l'odyssée de l'espace
c'est encore auto dans wall-e ou même ça
peut aller jusqu'à matrix ou cette
intelligence ambiante est devenu
tellement puissante qu'elle reconstitue
le monde dans lequel vous vivez pas ce
qui est étonnant de voir ici c'est que
la science fiction n'a pas généré
d'exemple positif de ça on n'y voit que
des exemples négatif en fait on a peur
de cette intelligence ambiante
et c'est vrai que bien souvent s'est
toujours défini comme quelque chose de
strictement utilitariste c'est ce
personnage là qui est en face de nous
mais qui s'assume pas complètement il
est là que pour exécuter une dix mois un
service un aspect très très rationnel de
l'interaction qu'on peut avoir et moi
franchement j'en ai un peu marre que
tous les objets autour de nous soit
uniquement dédié à au service à une
dimension stricte strictement
rationnelle où on a mis de côté la folie
et on s'occupe seulement seulement du
service je crois qu'ils ont oublié
quelque chose dans ce robot il ya
quelque chose d'important quelque chose
qu'on avait peut-être dans les robots à
papa et qui là d'un coup a disparu je
pense que l'objet qui manque enfin en
tout cas la caractéristique qui manque
c'est l'altérité c'est à dire de pouvoir
sentir cette intelligence sentir ce ce
personnage existe est devant nous avoir
une interaction avec lui et pour
illustrer sa je vais vous raconter
l'expérience qui a été menée en 1211 par
le roi frédéric ii
donc ce roi était convaincu qu'il
existait une langue qui l'incliné très
naturellement de la bouche des hommes il
a recherché et il a demandé à ce qu'on
isole quelques bébés dans une pièce sans
leur offrir la moindre interaction c'est
à dire pas de contact direct
on les regarde pas on leur sourit pas on
leur parle pas et donc bien évidemment
vous en doutez aucune parole nenê il
pensait que ce serait le latin ou le
grec qui sortirait de la bouche de ses
enfants
aucune parole n'est né dedans danser ses
enfants mais bien au contraire tous les
bébés se sont laissé dépérir et au bout
et assez rapidement
ils sont décédés de cette de cet
isolement
et ça pour moi ça montre quelque chose
de très essentiel ça montre que nous
sommes des êtres relationnel des êtres
sociaux des êtres qui avons besoin des
autres pour être et en fait on a besoin
de se sentir exister aux yeux des autres
mais là aujourd'hui avec toute la
technologie qu'on a on a les moyens de
pouvoir se sentir exister aux yeux d'une
machine quand même fou
et en fin de compte ce serait peut-être
ça un robot donc ce robot serait une
espèce serait cet être qui nous
regardent ce serait une espèce nouvelle
que nous créons et qui s'installe comme
notre reflet
ce serait un personnage qui porte sur
nous un regard qu'on souhaite
bienveillant ça serait un regard qui
nous invite à reconsidérer le monde qui
nous entoure et à y voir le merveilleuse
qui s'y cachent
ça serait un regard bienveillant et
curieux et qui a tout à découvrir et qui
peut tous de venir
c'est dans ce cadre là il ya trois ans
avec cette vision là que j'ai voulu
créer un nouveau projet ce nouveau
projet il s'appelle spoon et l'idée
c'était de rassembler cette vision
diffuse de l'intelligence et de lui
offrir un corps voyez derrière moi le
premier robot qu'on a fait on a passé
beaucoup d'énergie à trouver les
mécanismes de cette altérité dire quand
je vous regarde quand on interagit
ensemble qu'est ce qui se passe dans nos
yeux à quel moment ils vont se faire
mais pourquoi ma tête va bouger comment
nos corps vont se positionner à quel
moment on va répondre à un sourire ou
répondre à un regard ou d'une main qui
s'approche c'est c'est le genre de
mécanisme qu'on a beaucoup travaillé et
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'intelligence
animale
bien sûr ces robots exploite les
services et les capacités qui sont
apportées par le logiciel mais mais
l'idée c'est de pouvoir réinstaller
cette altérité
mais soyons bien d'accord l'idée quand
on installe celte altérité qui va amener
de l'empathie et qui donc amène de
l'émotion ce n'est pas de faire de
l'émotion pour l'émotion on cherche pas
à créer des robots dont vous allez à
tomber amoureux c'est vraiment pas le
sujet au contraire on veut se battre
pour ce qu'il ya plus beau selon nous
c'est à dire est ce qu'il ya de plus
beau c'est pouvoir interagir avec
quelqu'un pouvoir saisir un regard
pouvoir vivre en soit l'émotion que
quelqu'un de pouvoir se faire une idée
de l'idée qu'à l'autre pouvoir
construire une idée sur la base de ce
qu'on a compris de ce que pouvait être
l'autre et quand on fabrique des
machines et en particulier des machines
social pour moi on doit garder ça en
tête c'est à dire l'idée ce n'est pas de
ceux ci
situé à la présence d'un autre humain
mais au contraire de ramener d'enrichir
la relation qui peut exister en
différend entre différents êtres humains
de ramener du du merveilleux de ramener
de de la poésie dans la réelle relation
qu'on peut avoir et c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi de une illustration
c'est une illustration de mystique voilà
je les croisés au hasard dans les rues
de paris il ya deux ans et elle cite
elle reprend théophile gautier en nous
disant la poésie est un luxe de première
nécessité de la même manière je trouve
que cette cette présence cette
reconsidération de l'émotion dans le
design de machines d'algorithmes de
robot est un luxe de première nécessité
et bien sûr ces robots sont l'héritage
de la logique du rationnel on a créé des
logiciels pour ça et avec vous un
instant j'aimerais qu'on imagine ce que
pourrait devenir ce logiciel si on lui
insérer un peu de folie un petit
rationnelle un peu d'émotion un peu
d'empathie et pourquoi pas ensemble on
pourrait inventer ce soir le concept
d'un hymne au ciel voilà je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]